herzlich willkommen zum dritten Teil der
Camper ausbauserie wir haben im letzten
Teil das höhenverstellbare Bett gemacht
schon richtig viele Sachen die ganze
Verkleidung ist da die Sitzbänke sind da
das Bett ist drin mit dem
höhenverstellbarmechanismus auch mega
cool es fehlt aber natürlich noch sehr
viel ja wir haben noch ganz viel Sachen
vor unter anderem den Schrank natürlich
hier die Dusche mit warmwer und so
weiter und so fort dann natürlich noch
die Verkleidung bemalen Betonoptik dies
das und die Küche und natürlich auch die
eine oder andere side Quest und damit
kommen wir nämlich auch schon zur ersten
side Quest und die wird
offensichtlich wenn wir die Tür z ihr
seht hier ist die Küche und dahinter ist
natürlich die Tür und bevor wir jetzt
die Küche machen müssen wir erstm die
Verkleidung von der Tür machen und
fangen an mit einem Rahmen aus diesen
Leisten
hier und dann also so stell ich mir
zumindest vor kann ich das ja einfach
hier reinschrauben ich weiß einige von
euch haben geschrieben man muss ein
bisschen aufpassen wegen Rostschutz und
so mit der Schraube hab ein bisschen
recherchiert und das geht schon also das
kann man schon machen ohne dass es jetzt
irgendwie nach einem jah komplett
verrostet ist das wird jetzt
lustig dann geht jetzt hier ans Eck und
das wir ein bisschen schwierig weil wir
hier so eine Rundung rein brauchen aber
wir machen Verkleidung drüber deswegen
können wir hier eigentlich erstmal nch
so bisschen grob was reinschneiden das
ma jetzt erstmal mit
Augenmaß und dann kommt dann er halt
jetzt hier so da dran und nach dem
Prinzip machen wir jetzt hier einmal so
ein Rahmen rund um die Tür
drum boah schwere Geburt jetzt W wier
ein bisschen easy als nächste Stück von
hier bis
hier so bevor ich jetzt hier bei der Tür
die Verkleidung hier innen auch unten
machen kann muss ich er mal hier noch
mal sauber machen da soll nämlich später
bei der Küche hier noch eine Verkleidung
drüber dafür muss das ja alles bündig
sein und dafür sehe ich das jetzt mal
kurz
bündig na kurz ist gut
gesagt boah diese side quests
ne das war die
Lampe so und jetzt kann das später hier
richtig schöne Verkleidung dran nächste
zeitequ und zwar genau da wenn man die
Tür zumcht dann quetscht die hier gegen
dieses Stück Boden deswegen also das hat
der Vorbesitzer so gemacht deswegen sehe
ich das hier noch bisschen ab außerdem
soll hier später noch die Verkleidung
auch an die Küche dran drum muss es
weg und jetzt kann ich auch die Tür
zumachen habe halt da trotzdem noch ein
bisschen Platz um genau hier die
Verkleidung an die Wand dran zu machen
ich habe das gestern noch fertig gemacht
überall quasi so ein Holzbalken dran wo
wir jetzt so eine Platte dran spachsen
können das hier ist die Platte die ist
relativ huge ja ich habe jetzt wilde
Idee wie wir diese runde Form hier
abgezeichnet kriegen da drauf
sieht aus al W gerade festgenommen
werden geil ja und jetzt kann sie ein
anzeichnen Alter ich kann nicht
mehr junge echt
belasten wie ihr gerade seht bin ich
hier an der bandsäe und schneid so ein
Ding noch mal in Mitte auseinander und
zwar deswegen weil diese Tür ja die
schiebt sich nach hinten und die ist
dann angequetscht da hinten und das
wollen wir jetzt verhindern und das
haben wir jetzt damit gemacht in wir die
Dinger noch mal halben cenm dünner
gemacht haben jetzt wden
reingeschraubt so und es gibt noch eine
zweite Zeite Quest weil das hier oben
ist jetzt dünn genug ja das passt aber
wir sehen hier unten wenn wir mal ganz
genau reinschauen sieht man da ohne
jeden Zweifel dass da ja das bremst ne
das Teil hier steht da an deswegen sägen
wir das no ab und ich muss es gar nicht
rausnehmen ich muss es nur hier so ein
Stück absägen
idealerweise ohne die komplette
Isolierung zu zerstören was gar nicht so
leicht ist so dann tausche ich die
Schrauben noch mal kurz durch kürzere
aus weil unser Plan ist es jetzt das
Ding hier einfach viel näher
ranzuziehen so und jetzt wenn ich das
aufmache und nach hinten schieb dann
geht das ohne Probleme hinten durch das
penel ist jetzt erstmal dran jetzt fätür
auf okay da ist das Fenster jetzt weg
genau und der Griff ist auch ein Weg
deswegen markiere ich jetzt mal den
cutout für den Griff und zwar hier so ma
wir ganz grobes anzeichnen hier jetzt
brauchen wir einen groben ausschn fürs
Fenster der stichsge MA ich das also
erstmal ein bisschen
reinbohren
[Musik]
der grif finde ich ziemlich cool und
generell finde ich das ziemlich geil
dass man langsam eine Verkleidung si
nicht mal die dumme Tür das Fenster ist
ein bisschen tricky ursprünglich wollten
wir das hier oben drauf machen ich
glaube so hat sich das auch mal
irgendwer gedacht aber das kostet
einfach super viel Platz und ich finde
auch die Front also es wird edler
aussehen wenn man die hier nicht sehen
würde deswegen kommt das Fenster unter
die Verkleidung genau so wäre das dann
dran sieh eiglich solid aus aber jetzt
kommt eben noch die Verkleidung drüber
se gar nicht so leicht da wä erstm nur
einen groben cutout fürs Fenster gemacht
hatten muss ich den nämlich erst noch in
der Werkstatt präzise
ausen damit ist das jetzt fertig sieht
ziemlich geil aus das schauen wir morgen
rein hier sind auch richtig nice
abgerundete Ecken dran fin ich auch voll
wichtig das jetzt übrigens der erste Tag
bisher gewesen so viel schafft man an
einem Tag beim camperausbau nee stimmt
gar nicht heute schon der zweite Tag es
ist noch viel krasser als ich dachte
also wirklich zwei Tage haben wir jetzt
gebraucht nur für diese Verkleidung die
nicht mal fertig sondern die wird er an
Tag 3 fertig und ja also wie gesagt es
dauert insgesamt einfach Monate und
damit guten Morgen auch an diesem
wunderschönen Tag die nächste Mission
ist es jetzt quasi hier an dieses Teil
ja noch die Löcher für die Schrauben
dran zu kriegen das ist ein bisschen
schwierig gar nicht so leicht wie ich
das jetzt anzeichnen soll überhaupt weil
ja ein bisschen tricky drum ist mein
Plan jetzt dass ich diese Dinger wo die
schrauubben später reinkommen einfach
mal mit Eding richtig fett anmal dann
die Holzplatte deragegend drückt und
hoffentlich dann überall dann so ein
Kreis ist wo ich ein Loch rebauen kann
puh also einer in den Kommentare beim
letzten K geschrieben dass bei uns immer
alles direkt auf an läuft überhaupt
nicht so meistens lassen wir nur die
langweiliger Sachen ein raus jetzt ist
eben hier was und zwar kann ich die
Dinger nicht einfach so anmalen weil die
Teile noch nicht perfekt sitzen side
Quest also er jetzt z.B muss viel weiter
nach
[Musik]
unten muss ich erstmal das Fenster
komplett dranschrauben mit allen
Schrauben dann die anmalen dann das
dagegen drücken ich ma jetzt erstmal nur
drei Schrauben auf einmal vielleicht
vier einf bevor das ganze wieder
trocknet zweite Schraube und dann drücke
ich das hier ran oh das K richtig gut
und ich kann sogar dran lassen und da
kann ich jetzt einfach auch hier R an
also das hat auf jeden Fall mega gut
funktioniert man sieht die Kreise
richtig gut wo hier die Löcher rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sollen oh ich glaub das wird
gut diesecheiben sind jetzt nicht 10 von
ze optisch aber ich fin okay Streich
rüber ich ziehe jetzt mal die Folie
ab ganze Zeit dran aber jetzt wo das
Fenster endlich mal eingebaut ist können
wir h einfach den zuziehen und das
Fenster ist trotzdem geschützt wenn wir
hier dran bauen und so fliegenn jetzt
richtig coole Sache so noch kurz die
Aussparungen für diese Dinger
hier so kleiner Zwischenstand so sieht
jetzt die Tür aus ihr habt richtig
gesehen jetzt können wir endlich an
diese Küche dran gehen das hier oben ist
übrigens panzert dran gemacht damit ihr
den Regen abhält damit da nicht irwie
Schimmel reinkommt oder so ach so mir
fällt gerade auf da MS auch noch
Verkleidung dran machen bevor wir
weitermachen können geht jetzt um diese
Rundung hier und damit fange ich jetzt
hier an das wird ein bisschen
wildeaktion ja ist okay ist
okay ja ganz sch anstrengend jetzt noch
hier
oben
passt jetzt kommt z schwierigen Teil
diese Rundung hier die schön sein soll
die zeichne ich erstmal
ein so jetzt verbinden wir das unten mit
dem hier mit einem schönen
[Applaus]
Bogen ich glaub es ganz geil geworden so
nachdem ich das Holzteil nass gemacht
habe und dann bisschen gebogen habe ist
es ja z das finde ich gut ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch noch an den Akkuschrauber
erinen könnt aber den habe ich vor
langer Zeit für 142 € über Schub bei dem
Baumarkt bestellt und einfach 5,70€
Cashback dafür bekommen die Anmeldung
bei Schub unserem heutigen Sponsor ist
kostenlos und da gibt's etliche Partner
wie z.B mediaamarkt Ebay oder lierando
bei denen ihr Cashback bekommt Kön auf
so eine Essensbestellung sind es einfach
ein 2 € fürs nichts tun um eure Daten
müsst ihr euch keine Sorgen machen weil
Schub keinen Datenhandel betreibt
sondern sich einfach einen kleinen Teil
der Vermittlungsprovision einbehält und
sich dadurch finanziert der Rest der
Provision wird dann euch als Cashback
ausgezahlt einfach über die Schub App
oder den Cashback Assistenten für den
Browser auf euren Lieblingsseiten
einkaufen wie immer und ihr bekommt
einen prozentualen Anteil von dem was
ihr ausgegeben habt auf euren schup
Account gut geschrieben nur heute also
am Black Friday gibt's exklusiv bei
Schub 50% Cashback bei liferando für
Neukunden und 30% für Bestandskunden
wenn ihr bei lierando also zum ersten
mal was über Schub bestellt kriegt ihr
einfach die Hälfte davon wieder zurück
und das könnt ihr hab 10 € Cashback
direkt aufs Bankkonto oder per Paypal
auszahlen klickt jetzt auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung und meldet euch
bei Schub an und ihr bekommt 10 € extra
Bonus bei eurem ersten Einkauf so
mittlerweile hat die Küche auch schon
ein bisschen Verkleidung dran die
Rückwand hier ma ich jetzt daavor
braucht aber noch hier so zwei Streben
weil später soll ja drinen Esstisch
geben aber es soll auch hier einen Tisch
zum Ausklappen geben damit man draußen
messen kann und dafür muss es hier
richtig strong sein 885 und
63,2 so will ich drin
haben die Verkleidung hier steht noch
ein bisschen überum habe ich jetzt hier
einen guten alten
Handhobel und Hobel das Ding jetzt mal
bündig so und jetzt muss ich nur noch
diese Verkleidung hier dran machen eine
kleine Aussparung weil da ist so ein
Teil vom Auto ich wollte nicht abflexen
weil ich vielleicht ist wichtig und dann
wird's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
festgetackert fertig
nice langsam richtig gut Gestalt an
damit ist die Arbeits warte wie nennt
man das eigentlich ja damit ist die
Küche also was ist was ist da okay dam
ist der Unterbau der Küche erst fertig
machen wir mal die Arbeitsplatte drauf
genau jetzten wir hier gerade weil diese
Wand bisschen schief Aussparung die habe
ich mir jetzt hier schon angezeichnet
und die See ich jetzt
[Musik]
aus
hier passt passt unten auch das sieht do
wunderbar aus echt richtig geil aus D
wird jetzt festgeschraubt allerdings
natürlich nicht von oben der hässlich
sondern von unten oder Öl ich es direkt
ein ist die Frage ich lass das mal
Abkommen das wird jetzt ewig
dauern ach so fehlt noch was wichtiges
das
Waschbecken ma wir das doch zuerstch e
noch keinen Sinn hier irgendwas zu
streichen oder lackieren oder ölen oder
auch Schleifen noch nicht so jetzt ist
wir hier das
Waschbecken 250 € hat das Teil gekostet
schon ewig verstaubt liegt auch schon
seit anderthalb Monaten oder zwei
Monaten da drin weiß noch dass ich das
Teil mal mit Express bestellt habe weil
ich gedacht habe ich brauch es direkt so
kann man sich Iren das hat alles
bisschen länger gedauert als gedacht so
so geht das gute Stück auf schön
schwarzes Glas oben fin ich ziemlich
nice kommt da rein dann kann man den
hier so runter machen ah das ist cool
gut ich glaub ich habe das jetzt
angezeichnet erstes bauen wir mal
rein AUA ich glaub fter passiert Jes er
er war gut also ich glaube h braucht
irgende Art
[Musik]
Polster ist heiß Jesus Christ logisch
ist ist heiß das gibt eine Brandblase
aber instant so ich habe gerade nur
segblatt gewchselt we ich GLB schneller
[Musik]
gehen
passt rein sehr
cool so sieht die Platte jetzt geölt
aus nice fin ich richtig geil weil jetzt
jetzt sieht's aus wie eine Küche langsam
ma wir das Baby mal
fertig so und das ist jetzt so eine
wilde Absenkung da drin und da kommt
jetzt so eine Kappe drauf so dann ist
das erstmal schön ordentlich nicht nur
ist sie damit schon abgedeckt sondern
auch wenn man jetzt den hier runter
setetzt dann dann geht das Glas halt
nicht auf Schraube auf sondern halt auf
diese Kunststoff Dinger cool und dit
waschbeck erstmal
eingebaut gut auf jeden Fall kann ich
den jetzt hier runterfahren easy und
dann den Deckel drauf dann ist das hier
schön verstaut genau und die Platte hier
die muss ich jetzt noch festschrauben
weil aktuell
aktuell ja das muss ich von unten machen
weil klar wenn ich oben ma dann sieht
man die hässlichen Schrauben deswegen W
ein paar Löcher
reinschrauben okay da jetzt eine andere
Schraube reingebt das ist natürlich
bisschen schlecht ziemlich schlecht
sogar
so
hier
hier so sieht das Ganze übrigens von
unten aus mit dem Waschbecken und da von
unten machen wir auch die Schrauben
rein und
zack so so da ist er auch schon der Herd
ein guter Induktionsherd z Felder
Flexzone WT das heiß man könnte beide
benutzen wenn man fette Pfanne hat ja ne
hat ein Touchscreen finde ich nicht so
geil Touchscreen bei Herd wenn da Wasser
drüber kommt dann ist es immer super
nervig aber ja die Dinger gibt's kaum
anders und gleicht zum sauber machen
also ich messe das jetzt erstmal aus und
zeichne mir das mal so ein bisschen an
ob ich da platzmäßig rankomme ja also
das W jetzt wirklich der Hammer wenn das
nicht gehen würde die Lüftung ist s weit
ich weiß unten dran hier oben und unten
kann man ganz dicht drangehen 49,5 cm ja
und brauchen tun wir 49 num dre es passt
also genau rein wie viel Glück kann man
eigentlich hab im
[Musik]
Leben so das muss jetzt hier raus das
Mittel der W ist definitiv die Stichsäge
aber erstmal müssen natürlich ins Holz
reinkommen und dafür bä ich da ein
bisschen
rein tut eigentlich schon fast ein
bisschen weh da so reinzohen und jetzt
wird laut ach so ne wird nicht weil ich
kein Strom hab so aber jetzt wird's laut
da hat gefunkt das warahschein Schraube
ha na
[Musik]
ja das jetzt erstmal ein Loch
au e das muss SAS V gepolet werden so
von der Optik her finde ich es voll geil
also dieses Holz und dann diese
Schwarztöne und dann hier dieses
Edelstahl Ding ich weiß Edelstah ist
aber egal wahrscheinlich schon sieht
cool aus finde ich sehr geil so ein
Klassiker hier ist
Zugehör eine schöne Dichtung ja der
passt halt einfach gar nicht hin ne also
der muss da eigentlich auf das Loch da
drauf drum ja muss ich mir dafür wieder
irgendwie eine eigene Lösung
[Musik]
überlegen gut das war das Aluminium für
die CNC das ein bisschen anders als so
normales Alu das ihr vielleicht kennt
das ist viel pieksamer eigentlich drum
ja jetzt gebrochen ich seg mir mal
normales Alu
zu das kann jetzt auch komplett easy
biegen kann schon mit der handbiegen
sogar ist krass der
Unterschied ich hoffe das funktioniert
jetzt
[Musik]
mal ja das bombenfest das
Teil da bewegt sich gar nichts
[Musik]
mehr und das geile ist der her hat einen
normalen Stecker so uh da piept das ist
schon okay ich habe zum allerersten
maluktionsh am Start drum keine Ahung
hoffentlich klappt das jetzt wie ich mir
vorstelle wir machen nämlich jetzt
Pfannenkuchen g jetzt also so jetzt ist
es warm genug
ah krass da lernt man jetzt schon der
Kämpfer muss gerade stehen sonst kriegst
du keine geraden
Pfannkuchen sogar die ganze Pfanne
rutscht teilweise wenn der Boden schief
ist ja also meine Induktions Skills sind
auf jeden Fall noch schwierig das Teil
raucht jetzt auf jeden Fall bisschen ich
habe jetzt endlich deckt wie man das
Ding W macht deswegen ja ist es umso
besser dass wir das hier direkt beim
Fenster gebaut haben
oder wenn auch das noch nicht reicht
kann man auch einfach ganze Tür
aufmachen und dann raucht hier raus ja
mega geil schaut euch das mal an wie das
rauszieht beste Dunstabzugshaube der
Welt also ich muss zugeben ich habe um
Zeit zu sparen mir hier eine
Backmischung gekauft für den Pfannkuchen
und na ja also das ist auf jeden Fall
der erbärmlichste pfannenkuchenteig den
ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen habe
aber der her funktioniert und die Küche
funktioniert und darum soll es ja gehen
abonniert auf jeden Fall den Kanal wenn
Ihr sehen wollt wie es mit dem Camper
weitergeht schaut auch über den Link in
der Beschreibung bei Schub vorbei da
gibt's nur noch heute die Black Friday
Geschichte und ich bin damit raus